we wait to hear of the outcomes from the
nato summit it sounds like that a big
announcement is certainly on the way
what are you hoping for in terms of
their new strategic concept
well first and foremost i do not invite
yan stoltenberg at these times but
because the preparation of the strategic
concept of course has been a longer
process
than starting from this year and we know
that situation has radically changed our
neighbor at the east is totally
unpredictable we must think of the
unthinkable and nato as it always has
done has to quickly adapt
to be always prepared and to guarantee
that it's 100 track record of always
being able to deter any attack against
any nato member
is still doable in the future
we're expecting confirmation of a rapid
defense force to be increased from 40
000 to 300 000 i mean it is a huge
increase but for you does it go far
enough
well it's not only the rapid increase of
the forces which we will know about but
we also need to be trained exercised and
prepared in case things started going
wrong and we do not mean people or
russian army crossing onto any territory
of nato's country but let's say we have
something behind the border which we do
not understand and considering the
unpredictable nature of russian regime
we should then at this time know exactly
who will quickly come here already to
deter and who will also be ready to
follow on if the worst happens and our
commanders our military planners must
know exactly who does what and when and
where this is not currently the
situation yet and i am quite sure that
this analysis of what russia is nowadays
will lead nato to the right decisions
currently the rapid defense force is
kept in home count countries uh
pre-assigned to defend the baltics if
need be
are you happy with that or would you
like the troops to be
boots on ground physically based in
estonia and the other baltic countries
well so far the current situation has
been entirely satisfactory because if we
are ready to move
at the slightest signal of
as i said change of situation behind
nato's eastern border it doesn't i
repeat it cannot be already a real
attack on any nato member but if we are
ready to react to early cycles in case
of ukraine for example the signals were
there for months and months if we are
ready to react at that time period to
make sure that our adversary knows there
will be much more forces facing them
than is the normal level
then this is the most important element
which nato can do and has to do it
cannot be that when something
unpredictable finally happens then we
gather in brussels start discussing then
we see what we can scramble together
this
will be not enough in the current
circumstances looking at what russia has
been able to do in ukraine
boris johnson has talked a lot about
estonia the last couple of days of
course uk troops we know are based in
estonia and what do you make of his
plans to expand its european
headquarters there
yes indeed
part of this planning scheme for our
commanders to know who is doing what
when and where is exactly this we have a
command structure ready we have a
structure into which the following
forces will then fit and this is indeed
a good plan and i totally understand
boris johnson really
making the statements what he is mating
because during the enhanced forward
presence presence in estonia uk army has
also learned a lot about territorial
deterrence in estonia and potential
defense and therefore the steps taken
now entirely logical
i mean you are estonia's former
president uh i think the youngest
president as well to boot i mean how
concerned are you about estonia's safety
i mean how much do you think the country
is at risk because of what vladimir
putin is doing in ukraine
look i i'm not that young that i
wouldn't remember soviet occupation
and even if to some let's say brezhnev
time seemed like okay rather funny i
mean an old man
probably not very aggressive
but you have to understand during soviet
occupation speaking up against the
regime meant jail prison
even to the time of prisoner and this
did not change stalin died gulags stay
we remember a lot
about how russia is an occupation force
and even as an occupying society acts in
occupied territories so this is not
about territory land grant it is about
people's lives rape murder this happened
in my country in 1950s gradually the
level of violence went down but they
also did not compromise those who did
not did not work with the regime they
were still jailed
this is what russia has always been this
has not changed
and we hear that last night turkey has
reached an agreement with sweden and now
it may be that the pathway if you like
is open for neutral countries sweden and
finland to join nato
how significant a move is that do you
think
i believe that our military uh people
are actually very happy because the
situation around the baltic sea
radically changes for example russia has
been very prone to send its submarines
and and other ships into the baltic sea
and gulf of finland to be visible during
the exercises now this will be inner sea
of of nato so obviously a lot changes
but of course our collective defense in
northeast corner of nato will be
considerably strengthened by by this
move
so the big question which we haven't
asked yet is what message of course this
sends to putin but also how's he going
to react now that he's faced the
prospect of finland joining nato and a
new 800-mile nato border right on his
doorstep
well he's unpredictable but maybe our
nerves in the west can be calmed by the
fact that when putin has very often
claimed that he's afraid of nato's
expansion and this is why he's doing
what he's doing in fact he's lying and
we have caught his lie out you know how
we know this because right now behind
the borders of nato countries who have a
border with russia
there is nothing the level of forces
behind norwich north-eastern borders of
nato
is extremely low compared to the normal
times so
our nerves can be calmed by the fact
that right now there seems to be
inability to react in any forceful way
but of course we do
expect stratcom exercises we do expect
cyber attacks
trying to show as if societies in in
northern countries or in baltic states
or wherever are not on the same page and
not agreeing i mean this is all we do
expect but this is anyway this is this
is normal in this corner so first and
foremost there shouldn't be any physical
danger because all russian troops are
engaged in ukraine second we do expect
that all kind of hybrid things could
happen